we are Bonjour Madame Monsieur say
priyanka la vela Barbic Mon Ami
Steve Burnett ah Kazim
well fighter and Nikita she say I'll cry
abrasive magnifique
merci beaucoup maxi Mon amis Missa me
papa
cristela bah sorry guys I like to start
every podcast when Brennan isn't here in
French well luscious is that correct
yeah oh no oh you're speaking Spanish I
was yeah I was speaking I studied too in
eighth grade and I messed it up I
understand I cross the streams yeah
tark you speak various languages yeah I
do I do gratulations so much and I like
your pink shirt
we're here with two of my favorite
people I do actually I do it's cute
Targa seem and you guys have heard me
talk about he and his brother Yosef Azim
the ax seems are very close to me and
Brennan and then we got Steve Byrne from
my money one of the greatest comics
period ooh
with your new documentary the amazing
Jonathan yes you just went and did this
documentary about this musician comic
whose magician a magician comic whose
road manager was like 18 years old what
started at 12 yeah
so Jonathan great comic magician Vegas
headline or international act and he met
basically kinda like befriended this 12
year old kid that was constantly
backstage whenever he'd go to Australia
so every year go to Australia kids 13
can I have an autograph kids 14 can I
have an autograph basically kind of
gives him little responsibilities
teaching some tricks along the way and
every year that this kids getting a
little older and at 18
Jonathan hires him and Joel Osbourne
comes out to Las Vegas to be Jonathan's
road manager and he saw Jonathan through
drug addiction a nasty divorce suicide
attempt the perils of Las Vegas
basically kept him alive
and then Jonathan's diagnosed with
cardiomyopathy
so he's gonna he's learning he's got a
year to live and he outlives
expectations and it makes a return of
stage and while that was going on Joel
had gone back to Australia to become a
comedian on his own and then Joel came
back to
open for Jonathan in the film so Hannah
come circle yeah damn why did you choose
to do this well Jonathan was the first
guy I ever kind of featured for I did
two weeks back-to-back I did charlie
good night so I did Brian Regan was my
first week and then Jonathan was the
second week and Jonathan's comedy was
rooted in the magic but the magic would
always fail so as a watching him
Thursday than Friday to show Saturday
through Sunday one show and I got to
know the act
I was just sitting there going to do a
magic trick it takes maybe three beats
to do a magic trick that fails but then
it works and you get a laugh is six
beats yeah and there's a lot more
creativity that goes into making it to
deconstruct it and break it down yeah
make a laugh out of it and I was just
like blown away so I just kept in touch
with Jonathan and Joel over the years
and every time went to Vegas or LA I
hung out with them and when Jonathan
announced on making return of stage I'm
sick of waiting to die
I thought that'd be a great doc somebody
should do that and then I just kept
thinking about I know Jonathan I know
Joel I know their story and I saw the
story beats all play out in front of my
in a my head at night I just called him
I said can I do this film he said
absolutely and that's a while yeah dude
being a magician comedian in Vegas that
that's that will make you kill yourself
when I go to Vegas I'm just like oh god
damn it like yeah we met Brendan and I
Jimmy JJ Walker open for us I'm sorry
that's right
imma say it again Jimmy JJ Walker from
good times
yo yeah I know man I might give me 30
minutes 72 yeah and he looked at us and
he went see you guys are the traveling
act I was like well yeah I mean
technically he goes see you do oh comedy
do I said no no we were just gonna go on
separately he goes okay okay it's funny
I know everybody and I saw you guys and
I thought to myself we said he said kept
saying lights how does that mean you
didn't he always had a problem with
Brennan Brennan when - he's great there
he was really funny get up on yeah he's
a great guy he totally cracked me up
he's so funny but he did really well on
stage and then Brennan went he brought
Brennan up Brennan Schwab
and Brennan goes up and Brennan goes to
shake his hand it goes don't touch me
brother available his body out he had a
problem Brennan said for no reason he
loved me ahead brother Brennan he's a
dog for us he's not a cat person there
you go yeah dog no I'm the cat dog no
your dog no Joe you're a lamb no like to
lag you like affection bro
bro you want somebody throw the ball for
you friend throw the ball friend I work
at night from no one a work at night
yeah - I when I move you don't hear
anything till it's too late
yeah when Matt is too late yeah when I'm
out of town and I I come in and my
wife's hair is all messed up yeah yeah
cats need a little kid in that squad car
you're like all your wife kitty litter
where I dump thank you that's gross no
not kitty a catnip [__] yeah I blew that
hole Joe get me some cat yeah and also
when I take your back if you and I get
in a tussle I'd get destroyed well
because I take your back bro
cats cats take your back toggle it knows
no I don't think I think you're a dog I
think every time I see Brent I don't
know Brendon all that much I down the
podcast I see him at the store but it
seems a little more recluse into himself
yeah unless he's with it and around me
he's a cat cause he's like yeah I got it
here well what kind of dog would he be
if I was a dog him oh lab lab yeah well
a big ol last bull shanlee dog [__]
he likes he brings the ball he sits
there Pat's ass off
hey dude something's always out the pink
things he's humping pillows what do you
what kind of dog do you think I am and
he's always off his leash they try to
leash him up it'll always he'll gnaw
through that leash intake on
yeah you can't I can't be contained our
oh he's humping the neighborhood I'm a
Roman dog yeah yeah you're a bear I'm a
bear you're an Afghan bear I was
watching a workout so this [__] guy
yeah
brings me out yesterday he goes come
meet at 10 o'clock at the gym so if for
those you guys don't know Tariq is a
high-level MMA coach high level strength
and conditioning coach his clients are
the some of the biggest baddest names in
the MMA world you know people like Luke
Rockhold etc and and football players
like dion jordan and stuff so when you
go into his gym it's literally like the
who's who of the MMA / NFL it's so crazy
and then you'll walk over and see a hole
mention names but you'll see like some
of the biggest politicians and some of
the biggest like CEOs of the tech world
it's so hilarious in this gym so I love
going there I'm always like hey look I
recognize that guy from the newspapers
so this [__] guy tells me to come
chris matthews can benchpress 480 yes
you can a lot of them are strong there's
certain there's there's certain guys who
I know I happen to know from the tech
world in politics who are like super
successful then it hurts my feelings
that they're also bigger and stronger
and better look into me that kind of
[__] me up but but like CNN's roster
it's like Van Jones Anderson Cooper or
Don Lemon those guys are gym rats they
they were a dreamer yeah well because
when you're gay you need to look good
and other men want you to have abs it's
love much harder when it is just in this
just in and Don Lemon and but this
[__] guy goes meet me at 10 we'll
vote you want to come work out yeah I
get there
I get there and it's Marcus Peters than
one of the best quarterbacks in the
league
yeah it's dion jordan it's this other
kid 24 year old cornerback from miami
who plays on plays for Miami and then
Nick what's whatever next last name Aden
Nick Baden who plays is the only
fullback to be drafted in the NFL the
last gym I belong to was like teacher
faculty it was like a woodshop teacher
it was a truck driver it's just bad
that's what you want to do yeah instead
I'm when I work with people I work out
with Pete yeah not many successful
people there I'm with um
cream of the crop of the NFL yeah and
then I'm doing I'm doing leg a leg
workout with them and what's [__]
crazy is this guy doesn't use weights
he just has him everybody's going and I
was I was trying to do it and then he
goes let's go to the field and I go I'm
not going to the field he goes he looks
at me goes you gonna want to cover this
alright and we proceeded to do various
football drill slash Sprint's including
running routes while a cornerback was
covering me Oh God and yeah I can NFL
caliber that's right and I juked them I
juked them and caught the ball i jus did
no absolutely didn't I I've never been
that slow it was that I mean I mean I
was like what is going on national I
mean what do you expect that's somebody
that dedicates their entire life to one
thing and so we'd like to speed is then
they weren't even opening up but the
speed is so weird they're just like oh
yeah
[__] I'm gonna sue my parents yeah after
that it's a humbling experience yeah so
my body's my body's a little sore right
but for your age yeah your I mean right
yeah not only that now you give it to
them against one of the best in the
workhorse probably one of the best in
shape comics better than tullia for sure
excuse me yeah yeah I mean I've seen it
I've seen everybody's Instagram and for
sure your long march on the long march
D'Elia has to get on my back oh yeah
because his legs first of all he doesn't
have legs so his legs he's got Smurf
legs and they give out because he
doesn't have character he's a man with
character has strong legs yeah legs are
what tell the [__] story yeah yeah
yeah when it's time to bear down your
legs your ass ask the [__] strength
coach slash motivational [__] guru
over here
true or false have you ever seen
somebody that just does legs and no food
no Chester because it's always the
opposite right in the office and I've
seen the legs part primarily on the
cycling side of things right right yes
of legs slow-mo coming up from the
ankles off you're thinking this guy's
going to be some 240 pound linebacker
right second passes his hips then
there's really not much up there I
cyclers but it's usually somebody else
to see the other way around right
always yeah I was such a big arms and
absolutely no lady my daughter was
getting swim lessons the other day and I
went to the gym and this dude was it was
funny because it was like you couldn't
have plotted it any better if you were
like making a movie he's around a fence
and like this little brick thing and
he's going around the dude is yoked and
then he rounded it and it looked like
like Captain America Steve Rogers but it
only half worked so the legs were so
skinny but then the upper body was
absolutely jacked and he never did a leg
day kids ride love you'd love to get
ahold of that guy Oh God
do your leg workout literally I was
doing I can't understand what the [__]
you were doing I've never had a leg work
likely no squatting no nothing he looks
at me he goes I got to know where you
are before I added weight I got to just
see where you are so do most of you
you're just doing it off of like your
own like resist like being half I mean I
have to right yes it's a very very
delicate situation of these guys get
hurt right and putting em in a situation
I mean kind of assuming that they're
capable of being able to some sort of
explosive work with with weight and
really understand the dynamics of their
body's reaction to things right right I
usually start camp or our training
session with a ton of bodyweight
activation and some people you know who
aren't strong enough like Brian you just
keep them there on the because it's true
it is true because I was lead weight you
don't you don't know these dudes didn't
who was craziest these guys were sopping
wet and he didn't use a [__] weight
and there are plenty of weights there
but that was what was crazy and on top
of that you were doing exercises I had
never seen before I've never seen that
weird ball thing you were doing
you have the crap I have been around
enough like CrossFit gyms I've done a
lot of this stuff I've never seen enough
men's in enough bathroom stalls on the
president yeah been in a lot of yeah
I've just I've held a lot of I've
secured a lot of men I've spotted a lot
of men when they squat and when when
they [__] about lots of things like that
whereas you were doing workouts I've
never actually seen those [__]
exercises it was so weird
yeah well so for if you had to like let
if there were five exercises
five I could do the rest of my life what
would they be it depends right like I
had to create when I when I share and
teach because of what's happened to me
right with all my operations on my spine
yes sir Tariq played d1 ball at Fresno
and a lot of what I'm doing and what I'm
teaching is primarily based on
preventative injury right don't
necessarily oh my god this is gonna make
you faster and this is gonna make you XY
and Z eats here's what's gonna make sure
you're not hurt I mean rather these guys
are such great athletes that's why they
are where they are yeah right like I'm
not going to add to what got them to
where they got to what I can do is
protect what they have and a lot of that
has come just from being injured getting
hurt being coached wrong you know seeing
things you see a massive consistency and
then in a very particular industry like
CrossFit where I mean I don't believe
CrossFit's a sport of its own like it
shouldn't be a sport of its own it's a
really good compliment interactivity to
a sport yeah but but I will say that my
joke about CrossFit and I have a lot of
respect for it but I my joke about
anybody who takes does CrossFit
well they look great but this day I will
here this without without fail I'm
getting back into it my neck my shoulder
injury is it common it's the way it is
and and I should say that about and I'm
nobody I know what it means a joke not
CrossFit I don't do instruction to write
like yeah you've got some of the most
renowned coaches in the world who are
actually CrossFit experts yeah awesome
but then you've got a lot of individuals
who do CrossFit then go out and try to
coach it that's without having the
understanding of why you're doing what
you're doing that's why a lot of
injuries that but it happens in
everything well how many people in
jiu-jitsu have how many people in
jiu-jitsu don't have a neck or back
problem how many seriously how many
black belts don't have an issue with
their neck right yeah I mean you see
that across the board in every sport
yeah that's why I don't do it right like
that's that's why I just you just street
fight
I just street fight yeah well I Steve's
been in some fights here his jaw broken
I had my jaw broke and tell a story
about the job look he doesn't need to
fight though look at his address well
his head oh my bad
what his eyes why did you say that just
like well wait that happened again
what do you
yeah I promise
no your eyes where she's sweating man
when I walked away three times he just
looked at me and he just say stay
hydrated tight I was like what does that
mean huh Chris kept saying stay hydrated
tonight I'm like what are you talking
about I just met you yeah over and over
again yeah but I think I can't I grew up
I think we're probably all I'm 44 so
[__] I grew up when there was no MMA
like as it is now so you just went out
and you just did what you did and to the
best of your ability yeah so just that a
tussle if you got a tussle but the
greatest I mean I I got like you know I
got popped in many times like in college
I got this just from you know I pulled
up to this parking lot and these guys
were all standing there and I go hey can
you guys move and they just wouldn't let
me exit and they were hammered I go can
you just move in this guy he comes over
to my door he goes what I go can you
move please this is 2:00 in the morning
he need just fat just drugs just right
there got popped it's bleeding I get out
the dumbest thing I could do I get out
and there's six of them and they just
start beating the [__] out of me and
it's just the 90s so everybody had Doc
Martens on and I just remember all these
Doc Martens kicking me probably had like
a whole game concert was it was bad but
this is the greatest fight I've ever
been in in my life and I was in Phoenix
Arizona I did the Tempe improv so we
finished the show we meet some girls we
go to the pool I mean this other comic
partition off with these girls whatever
and we we all hang out and then
eventually I'm like all right well these
girls are getting out of here I'm gonna
walk them to the elevator he goes on I'm
gonna stay here I'm like I'm just gonna
welcome the elevator so I go to catch up
with them on the lobby and these girls
are in the elevator and there's a dude
holding the elevator doors open and
these four boys are behind them and
they're all black guys so I it plays
into the story I'm normally would not
say it but it plays in this draft this
african-american that's what you're
supposed to say it's whenever I didn't
feel safe saying that type of stuff when
I'm around yeah I love the blacks
yeah yeah well you're Afghani so you're
you're you're in the club you're not
great
I mean it's like my buddy said right not
too long ago you got it worse than us
man why at least I can wear a backpack
to the airport it's always clean-shaven
it's a truth it is junk
so these guys hold the door open and
he's like come on give me your number
give me a number
she's like I'm not giving him my number
and I'm walking up my god Christ what do
I do and I go well I go under the guy's
arm and I pop up and I'm like hey guys I
get it you know we're all just having a
good time here tonight he's completely
ignoring me he's like girl give me a
number give me an AK she's like I'm not
giving you my number and he holds up his
chain he's like you can't handle this
bling you want to roll with this bling
she's like I'm not giving you my hammer
I don't want your bling he goes come on
come on you know I'm not closing these
doors until you give me a number
she goes I'm not giving you my number
you and then she dropped the unborrowed
she did now I'm like oh she did oh yeah
yeah she's a white girl yeah so what
this girl's in the corner of the
elevator kind of an [__] Ren's there
I didn't know she was she was pushed to
it they still no excuse still so the guy
enters the elevator now okay and I kind
of stand in front I'm like whoa and we
just grab each other
so I played ice hockey all like you know
all through my life right and I just
when you're playing hockey you you know
this is back in the day where you pulled
the Jersey woman as an enforcer mode so
I went to in first remote I pulled the
Jersey I pulled his shirt over his head
and I'm just going for broke
I'm just drilling him especially how did
that happen because he was about to I
don't know what he was doing but he he
came over and I got in the way and next
thing I know he grabbed me then I
grabbed him and were tussling around and
then I pulled it the shirt over his head
and I'm just going for broke
because I'm in a confined space I'm like
I got to go all in so I'm just hammering
him I'm hammering I go you done are you
done he goes chill dog chill and I'm
just hitting him I'm like are you done
are you done he goes chill dog juggle
are you done he goes I'm done I'm done
now what I didn't realize is when we
were moving around we shifted the
elevator off gear so we're stuck the
elevators stuck
are the doors closed the doors are
closed cause the word were you and you
got his four boys behind you no they're
all outside with thank god yeah they're
out there okay so he's in the air
these girls are crying I'm standing
there I remember Sarah smiles by Hall
and Oates is playing and I'm just you
know me and I'm like aw [__] this is
awful and so I'm just looking at him
like at any second this guy is gonna
come back at me when she catches his
breath and he's looking at me but he's
looking at me a little different way and
then he were just sitting there and I go
man this is so [__] up he's like this
is really [__] up and he keeps looking
at me and I'm like this guy's definitely
gonna hit me so be prepared and he looks
at me and he just kind of like turns
towards me goes were you on BET's
comicview I go yeah he goes did you do
the Bruce Lee bit I go yeah he goes what
are you doing here I go I'm at the Tempe
improv doing shows or whatever you know
if you want to come see a show that's I
met these girls he's like yeah crazy
right so then all of a sudden here
ye and the elevator goes back to the to
the lobby all the sudden the doors open
his four boys rush in and pop pop pop
I'm getting drilled beating you up he
gets in the middle he goes no no he goes
you guys guys guys don't hip this dude
was on BET's comicview they go and then
one guy goes you do the Bruce Lee bit I
go yeah they go oh listen that's awesome
in India the lobby guys like I called
the cops so they bolted the girls go
back in the elevator come back down and
I'm standing there and my shirt is
ripped I got popped here I'm bleeding at
the mill because I just got leg and then
the other comic that I was with that
that was with the girls he comes out the
business centre holding a cappuccino and
he's just staring at me he's like the
[__] just happened dude I just left yeah
it's unbelievable razor yeah that was
that was the best fight howdy
your [__] ass oh you saved me uh
otherwise it would have been a victim of
a hate crime hey well I can't believe
that girl called
I would have died yeah hey [__] you
can never do that yeah when she said
that it was just like like why would you
do those the guys being a dick but Jesus
Christ yeah wow man that's that's bad
news
why I had one at the store one time at
the Comedy Store it was like when I
first passed this is the dark days at
the store nobody's going on I mean you
remember those so Friday eight people in
the in the oh are everything
to shut down I'm on stage and this guy
said that her exaggeration you'd be on
stage doing stand-up at 11:30 it'd be 12
alcoholics like in like literally like
scattered nobody was there
it was awful everybody said the improv
or the factory cuz Dane was poppin with
the factory and the improv was all the
industry's was like Zac and Demetri and
all those guys there but so is like me
Sebastian you whoever else you know and
there's this guy sitting there with like
six of his friends and as I'm being
introduced these three Asian kids get up
and they walk out of the room so as I'm
going onstage this guy goes hey your
friends left I go what he goes your
friends left you I go oh you mean the
Asian kids he goes yeah your friends and
while he's doing this I'll never forget
this but he brought [__] chicken it
with chicken wings in with him so I see
Santa he was going like this what and I
was like [__] [__] this [__]
piece of [__] in a mic mic mister just
balling up and I normally don't take the
bed I go well maybe I'll go outside and
[__] catch up with him he goes yeah
maybe you should I go maybe you should
[__] meet me he goes maybe I will I
go well let's [__] go so I get off
the stage and you know how there's like
that the rooms a big rectangle so I'm
going towards the desk and he starts
coming over and I just grab him and I
just start [__] drilling him and I
get him on the ground I'm doing like a
Ralphie from Christmas story believe me
for every one of these there's probably
well do this so I'm just [__] popping
him and his buddy picks up one of those
tables from the back of the Comedy Store
and you know how heavy those things are
they're made like the 60s they're
[__] really heavy yeah and the guy
picks it up and he goes to hit me with
it and Bret Ernst thank God saw the
whole thing turns right orange comes in
the guy yeah and Brett takes down this
guy and I think there was one other door
guy that took out one of the other we
didn't even have door guys yeah there
was we so it was just a melee and we're
just beating the [__] out of these guys
they were a little sauce too so then
they they kicked him out but uh that was
one more took the bait but one where I
definitely took the bait and things
didn't work out was the comic strip so
Upper East Side New York City
started it was my birthday dangerous why
[__] do you think you could beat your
ass no God no no we're gonna fight after
this no I don't know any of the MMA
stuff I would like more fight stories
than anyone I know I would get
absolutely smoked you got it about
people that know she Jake Shields and
the he can do some boxing kicking what
smile guys spars with guys like the high
level go yeah yeah I'm done with that
stuff you and Luke Rockhold like to yeah
we're gonna get it we're gonna get you I
got I want to pick your brain but this
was a lesson this was a great lesson I
learned is that it was my birthday I had
written a new bit and it was like that
Romantic period were like I got to work
on this bit it's it's great it's great I
go and at the comic strip I would get up
at like midnight so it was maybe like 10
people there and there's like these you
know bridge-and-tunnel kind of crowd oh
yeah and they stand up and they're
working on their bill talking during my
set I go guys can you just please take
it out there whatever it goes what are
you gonna do Jackie Chan and he just
goes back to my [__] so I'm just
doing my bit and I go guys honestly just
go out it you know I'm trying to work on
this bit and I go we gonna do you and
then he starts doing like that you know
this [__] like mocking me and a mic guys
yeah I'm like fat God the I said I got
the Lincoln tunnels open 24 hours a day
he was a man [__] you and they said some
other Asian thing and the girl like one
of those loud obnoxious Italian Jersey
girls whatever she said something and it
just [__] set me off and I go will
someone tell that [__] - shut up and I
dropped the see bomb and as soon as it
happened I was like no I should have
said that and next year no he picked up
one of the stools in the back there
pretty [__] heavy and he just zinged
it and I just saw this thing coming and
I turn around and it split the back of
my head open I got I ended up getting
eight staples on the back of my head and
I went to the ER that night and I waited
like four hours to get these staples in
and then what sucks is anytime something
like that happens in New York City in a
comedy club my head shot somebody
somebody scotch tape staples onto my
head and put it there and then they
cross my name out it said the chairman
so I just got rasz for that for last
whatever we do your job broken by a dude
got my jaw broken this I will say is not
my fault okay it kinda is but it kind of
isn't so I went to Beacher's Madhouse at
the Roosevelt and Roosevelt in LA yeah
okay so I went with my good buddy Gareth
Reynolds and and we I hadn't signed up
for uber this is when uber was just
coming into the into play and I go to
the taxi stand there's all like these
taxi cars waiting
and the next cab driver they were all
smoking so we're just sitting there
waiting for a cab sitting the wait for a
cab and I go hey could we get a cab
please and the guy goes yeah yeah yeah
yeah one second one second he's smoking
a cigarette and he's continuing to smoke
I go uh is like five minutes and I go
hey could we just jump in the next cab
or something he goes I said wait one
minute one minute and I go [__] hey
so he's taking his time he's telling his
stories catching up with his boys and I
just go uh I go seriously can we just
get a cab he goes fine and he comes over
I go you know what [__] I don't want to
get in your cab I'd like to get in the
next cab can I just get in the next cab
and so the guy starts coming over and
I'm walking past his cab and I Spit on
the back of the windshield
I hoped I spent on the windshield he
goes hey did you spit on my car I go
what and next thing I know that he just
hit me right before I could even react
he just [__] drilled me right in the
right and the Javad punch and I didn't
go down or anything but I knew something
was wrong
I just knew something was wrong I just
started bleeding and I was like no
something's wrong here something I and
so I just kind of like backed up a
second and then my buddy my buddy goes
hey did you just punch my friend he just
starts getting his ass handed to him I
mean this guy's drilling him with a guy
a boxer I don't know there's some
Armenian some Armenian Bobby knew what
he was doing I'll say that Armenians yes
especially if they'd lived in Russia
they were even in Armenia that that I
promise you if he's Armenian and he has
an accent he's talking like this yeah
and he's right he's done his share of
wrestling and boxing yeah he's been
what's you in the [__] face he
me and I just knew and then I went to
the ER that night and yeah they're like
yeah your jaw's broken like [__] okay
and this is in print while i'm in
production on Sullivan & Son oh oh now I
got to go in to meet with executives
with my jaw wired shut
that's and they're like I feel like so
what happened like well I tell you guys
I parrots things that they like they're
like it's either six weeks or eight
weeks and now they're trying to work on
the production if if my jaw takes its
disaster dude - it'll take six weeks if
it doesn't it'll take eight weeks and so
they're trying to work out I couldn't
move my jaw so I was drinking smoothies
for six weeks out of a straw Wow
yeah it was pretty brutal no that was
that's a very humbling experience when
you just don't ever spit on someone's
car again no I won't spend on anybody's
car and again yeah yeah minify probably
never know huh
but street fights never like you guys
growing up I never had oh I mean yeah
but I've had a ton of those like fights
growing up in a little school in high
school but as an adult overseas in
Afghanistan actually not understand but
boy is that with the American yeah yeah
those those mercenary dudes
oh those [__] guys yeah the way they
treat people out there gets wait for
real you really did that yeah yeah
actually mixed up after college for a
few years in 2004 to 2008 and Adam so
instead of getting like an internship
Manhattan you're like [__] it I'm gonna
go I want to learn how to farm to a
thick yeah okay I want to get in the
opium game I want to yes you're on the
air dude you are warlord there are
pictures of him with an ak-47 in full
I'm carb ya know my adult fights were
this literally in Afghanistan so it's
like and then Paula Paula Harris I tried
to attack once after Jake's fight oh
yeah counting I hate that [__] guy
[__] hate our corner and Jake Shields
and Steve Maserati who's the [__]
terrible the worst ref of all time and
who some are Paul Harris who's a who's a
piece of [__] there's something wrong
with him but he cheats he get you in
he gets you in leg locks and cranks on
your and
you know keep going oh it's a piece of
[__] he got a he got banned I think and
Steve Maserati is everything okay at
home Jake is everything okay he was
jacking Jenna Jake was dominating yeah
dominate dominate and Jenny was digging
these and and Steve [__] [__]
Maserati who's the worst person in the
world and so dark dark I guess she tried
to beat up PHA Harris well I know the
thing was that you kept dodging Jake's I
don't got to a point where like it was
its blood squirting out of his eye
uh-huh and he kept saying you know Jake
like would never ever try to make an
excuse to stop anything he just like
holding his eye and like hey you tell
him the raffle do you not [__] see
this I'm crying loud scream at the top
of my lungs cuz yeah keeps every time
Jake gets a dominant position he keeps
gouging his eye gouging his eye but Tony
wait he's a piece of [__] yeah yeah he's
a piece of [__] this guy
this [__] roid freak right here this
photo Jesus that looks like Brad Pitt's
an [__] the the the yoke dude yeah
yeah the yokai it looks like Brad Pitt
if he ate at Arby's and was roided-out
doesn't it yeah is there something wrong
on gouging wait that was him earlier
another guy in anyway that's him 24
hours apart know that truth know Jesus
Christ
yeah he's a scary individual he's a very
scary Nephi J yeah and he's he's still
fighting take me I'll [__] out of him
and then he ended up winning because Jay
couldn't see what is he doing now is he
like a bouncer hooter he got banned from
fighting I think after I finally got
banned in general right now and I was I
was we used to try to go fight in Russia
right up at kiss W promotion yeah
probably I wish we could find that
[__] I wish we'd find that [__]
thing where were it's you're talking
about him being uh basically it we don't
J couldn't see anything right he's
obviously couldn't see aiming both his
eyes just gouged out and he ended up
taking this Kimura right there on on on
Jake or the Americana and then Jake
tapped and he wouldn't let go he's such
a piece you know you wouldn't let go and
then he and he stood up and that he has
no character I thought I'd plant over
the cage and yeah he sucked
man as a person this is a bad guy he's a
bad guy sometimes you look at people go
you're a piece of [__] you're a bad guy
yeah you're just a bad person he's a
cheater he has no character he cheats so
he if when he's losing he'll stick his
fingers in your eye cuz he has no
character you see someone needs wind
sprints ten he needs to do so now he
needs to be he needs to be just kept
away from he needs integrity you know
the guys just raised by by animals look
at those traps holy [__]
yeah that's iLike the way you were
saying you're saying it's smart it's the
very emotionally she is like we had a we
had a degenerate for a little you know
referee and then we had an animal we had
to fight who was raised by animals so
it's very hard to find an animal that's
been raised by animals and with a
degenerate for a refuge he's literally
just all muscle though oh yeah oh yeah
but that's what all the steroids -
that's what all the steroids do yeah but
he's also got like a really high level
you know game probably as well I love a
fun just cuz you know his steroids that
he can hurt people but you see he
doesn't stop yeah when people tap
because his whole goal is to just ruin
people's lives yeah well we he sucks as
a person well I will not follow him on
Twitter don't spit on his car don't I
will not spit on his arm no I do not
look at look at Jake sighs that's the
next day Jesus Christ that's - that
[__] [__] did and that's not from
punches that's from sticking his fingers
no I thought that was an elevator ride
with Ray Rice hello hello mm-hmm let's
go to some current events I'm done with
these guys all right current events do
some current events so a video of a
woman licking the top of an ice tub of
ice cream is going viral and she
basically just opens up the tub licks it
puts the lid back on and puts it back
into the freezer and she just leaves it
for whoever else is gonna grab that ice
cream to go ahead and buy it and the
company Blue Bell ice cream is actually
talking to law enforcement now to try to
figure out who that woman is because
they're losing a bunch of money a lot of
people are saying that it's bluebells
fault for not having that plastic seal
at the very top of their ice cream yeah
but the way that they freeze their ice
cream is specifically upside-down
so the ice-cream naturally has kind of a
seal when you take it off already and
that's how you can tell but because of
this video they're now losing a lot of
money see this video Noble a leaky all
you file put a bit of a this six lanes
wide I think I said euro N word on
Halloween you dressed up about the Blue
Bell ice cream yes I did
opening it lit what I did yeah there was
a guy I used to work at a restaurant and
there was this this kid from Guatemala
or something and he didn't speak in
English they have a huge scar down his
face and I believe in honest throat I
think it had he had been cut really
badly by some gives a gang thing and you
could tell that he had nothing and he
was there and he was a busboy at the
restaurant he would work really hard and
then one day I am coming back upstairs
and our the owner of the restaurant she
is hiding behind the pillar and she's
looking and she goes and I know she was
wait what and you see this guy and he's
they used to put the little jellies he'd
put the jellies in those little cups
yeah put them on the table so little
jellies for breakfast right so he has
all the jellies on a tray and he's
licking every single one of them before
he puts them on there yeah so I and so
do I go I don't know kill him he can't
do that I don't know how do I go well I
could go tell him you can't [__]
little junkies and says she goes um go
tell him he can't lick the jellies and
then she was no maybe I'll have somebody
who's Spanish to it so she had another
guy go hey tell him to not lick the
jello
[Music]
okay Oh like he didn't even know he's
like it was a [__] weirdo yeah so we
collected the jollies off the tape honor
this strike one
they were so nice let's go let him go
over to shoes I guys probably a little
[__] up don't lick the dead that's a
thing that people have they want to they
want to put their thing
it's like that weird fetish that some
people have where they [__] where
they'll come into your house they'll
break into your house and jerk off in
your closet sorry oh yeah or though how
many you know how many times
Petar you buy a house wait oh yeah and
of course it's dudes it's always goods
yeah and of course even when you're in
the house they want to do something
really dangerous so they'll get in there
get in the closet jerk off and then run
away I've done that I mean weird there
are a lot of weird sexual fetishes Wow
I'm eating potatoes some yeah you know
okay yeah well have you ever had a girl
you ever been with a girl who said
something like well you're like I've had
plenty girls like you know girls broke
me once I had that [__] out of me what
no right yeah no no I can't beat the
[__] I don't know what that means
yeah no it's like having sex with this
girl one time and we were in missionary
and she just hit me and I go why she
just hit me I'm like Britney Spears okay
[Laughter]
the best is in Florida where the girls
are so hot she's from Colombia just
you're sad because I just wanted to
drink your blood I was like hey if I'm
being a that's that's right my jizz yeah
how about you can't trade my bloody you
can drink Jesus trying to feed the bird
mama Birds back chirp-chirp dad
ah I really dragged out the last one
time to feed the ball can't treat my
blood you can my favorite is when you
weird energies and you start naming
States ya know it's the map a while yeah
Hawaii looks like the big one there
comes the big one when it went when it
hit your back Tork what's the craziest
thing you've had whoa you can't go there
can you buddy now he's too classy heart
doesn't kiss and tell
that's okay how about you I've had a
girl asked me to choke her yeah sure
I've had a girl asked me to to rape her
because like [__] no no I'm not gonna
rape you yeah do ty yeah me rape me
hey no okay then you then you pretend to
be my defense lawyer or how about that
playing fantasy world
I mean exactly this you know yeah try
that she told me to rape her so that's
why that really flies especially yeah
public opinion did you rape her okay the
answer is yes let me finish already done
just answer yes or no yes oh yes or no
question yes yeah yes or no Brian okay
yes you raped her
[Applause]
hey what does map of Hawaii mean okay
look I can explain it is interesting how
you have people who I've had I have I
have to say I have had women's ask
excuse me say say say think like if say
mi you're a little you know and there
are various things that are shocking oh
you're into being treated yeah I don't
like here I don't like talking I don't
like I don't like I'm I don't want I you
you sit you seem like a talker here I'm
a talker my voice is so seductive you
know I mean yeah daddy you wanna go
shopping later see that's the problem
who's your daddy rich [__] it's like
it'll backfire on your hello you can't
turn it off guys okay hey you can't turn
it off you can't enter I feel bad I
think anybody that's watching this we
should put a disclaimer
fast forward to whatever minute mark
this this run was on ah so go in 22
minutes to the part where you you start
talking about tat tat tat tat yeah well
you were you the one telling me that we
were having coffee and that girl was oh
no that was Ryan me Luke and Ryan were
at that uses wedding there was a girl
who had her little stuffed animal and
she was kissing it what yeah sorry was
doing on a computer how old was she was
30 and she had a little stuffed animal
and she kept kissing and going yeah good
boy
yeah she was talking to it and Ryan goes
are you watching us are you watching
this and she had this whole crazy fetish
with this little stuffed animal yeah
lucky stuffed animal yeah well yeah I
see a little sting that sexual that what
turns people on a lot of times is the
weirdest [__] in the world some people
are into granny porn
grandpa porn some people are that's a
that's a fact
so yeah we're into there's an amazing
book called a billion wicked thoughts
and it looks at these two neuroscientist
one from Harvard the other from Boston
University looked at what people
actually they looked at the the major
porn the the hubs of what the words
people put in we are looking for when
nobody's looking you can get a sense
there is a billion we could thought what
the world's largest experiment reveals
about yeah
about sexuality basically and it's
really fascinating because when people
are on their computer and they're
looking up what turns them on mm-hmm
nobody's looking so you get a really you
get a real understanding about how
people behave and what they're actually
interested in so for example in Kenya
and in the UK in the United Kingdom
that's where granny porn is the most
it's the most prevalent okay
why why is that because you're raised by
older people when you're a kid because
our headmaster because your grandmother
a lot of times will be the one who
raises you so you imprint what sexuality
is sometimes on somebody who is older so
they they follow these really wild it's
the human psyche he's fascinating that
wing it's fascinating so you guys can
comment it's just you know it's a matter
I'm just getting nervous
let's all look at each other's web
browser his a look at this so so
percentage of sexual searches 13.5
percent popularity ranking category
youth free non-nude teen videos okay
four point six percent is category is
gay straight guys pay to have gay sex
that's a huge win among gay the gay
population four point three percent like
to watch milfs mom is the second most or
a derivative of mom or mother is the
second most popular word typed in
worldwide in porn searches so milf milf
sand bikinis four point more so than
like college well you know that's first
so anything related to youth is first
and second his mom right and then
breasts huge tits
for example search huge tits that's very
very popular cheating wives that's
another one by the way
cuckold porn is a big deal your local
cheese what's cuckold porn couples so a
cuckold it comes from its a
Shakespearean term for the cuckoo for
the cuckoo bird and the cuckoo bird will
use the other with will use will
lay its eggs in another bird's nest and
the bird raises those eggs it lets
another bird sit on those eggs and so it
let it makes another bird think that
those are its eggs so the bird will sit
on the eggs hatch those eggs but the
eggs actually belonged to this other
bird it's got perfect Maury Povich Show
you raise my kids [__] thank you
go the original working title the
blindside was the cuckold side the
cuckold side yeah hello sacré right
listen carefully alright dude gotta stop
sorry doing that okay we get it I can't
turn it off I know but I know but you
can already wise up look um that's I do
that after no I don't ya dum-dum what do
I do
yeah God but uh but that's so that's so
cuckold when you're a cuckold your wife
you get off and watching your wife you
get off on your wife cheating on you
that's really disturbing that's - that'd
be like the last thing on any list that
be very common my common vomit porn
would be ranked higher than me watching
my wife well 2.4% his giant [__] which
means I couldn't make a lot of money
important hello yeah look at this putz
here's my ass and then of course free
cheerleader porn okay if you're cheap
but you like I'm young free cheer later
point it's a very good book who's
actually a all the things you could look
up in sex though penis still comes in
seventh is it crazy what penis comes in
seventh
yeah weird so as much as like girls say
they watch porn like it they're not
watching they're not into that what you
would think that they would be why women
they find need a narrative typically so
women it's not true all the time
but but for the most part what's
fascinating about erotic porn ie what is
it called erotica so so graphic novels
that had that erotic novels very popular
among women
dick size is not important you never
ever hear it men you just say that one
more time I want to record this now that
phone but it's not what they describe it
as like there it's more about passion
it's about this sort of virile stranger
who can't help themselves carried away
with lust and
but it they did a narrative is very
important to the female psyche typically
right and they're just huge differences
in the way men and women look at sexy
[__] huge and typically men have zero
idea what turns a woman on and a lot of
times there's an experience that they
have a weekend with a woman what she
remembers is so different than what you
remember and we make this mistake
because as guys we're never we were
separated almost almost to every culture
boys and girls at the age of five to six
separate themselves voluntarily I have
children I can tell you this girls play
with girls boys play with boys and
almost always so and that continues all
the way up through college so think
about it by the time you start dating
somebody by the time you move in with a
woman you don't know how that person
thinks unless you have sisters and
you've been told how to navigate that
you're living with a stranger what's the
one thing you hear men say all the time
about women she's crazy you know because
you don't understand how she thinks and
you don't understand what makes and I'm
as guilty of this as anybody you don't
understand what what's actually
important to her at 52 after going
through therapy yeah couples therapy I
have I'm uh I'm a blue belt I'm a blue
belt I mean I I'm I'm woefully ignorant
I'm constantly surprised about and women
don't understand how men will say things
with no psychology on it a lot of times
men will just say [__] and there is no
one who do you [__] you want just tell
me what you [__] would write yeah
right well you're like a white Steve
Harvey the way you break it down and you
let us know I think ultimately though if
I were to analogize like men women have
to do like a man and woman bit or
something but I I always thought like a
soap opera is what the woman wants and
then the porn scene is what the guy
wants and if you could just combine the
two cuz you're you're getting all the
buildup the steamy romanticism right I
think that's what the women want the
narrative yeah and then the guy just
wants to see okay well they're good luck
all right let's just see him bang yeah
and that'd be the perfect hybrid of like
we could watch this together yeah I will
say that as men and women
older I think they start coming to guys
starting together I think so like so so
you you what do you think it's
necessarily age or anything it's just
experience I don't know if life
experience I want to be it's gotta be
it's not a ladder I think you spent a
lot of time helping people kind of
change the way they think and I know you
do that with a lot of men and a lot of
people who really need that quickly and
you're kind of a master it you are I
mean you're the SPN just did this whole
spread on Tariq about being kind about
well with what they say is a
revolutionary coach and and you've
earned that title because I think you're
really good at you always say that most
human beings basically all want one
thing not better than her Brooks though
the 1980 gold wedding oh that sir but
thank you basically peep men and women
human beings want one thing and are all
the same fundamentally right now in
essence acceptance acceptance that makes
sense so but have you had a lot of
experience with women in dealing with
this because I know you have a lot of
female employees and stuff like that so
you and to work with you is always to
have a game plan to work with you you
get really specific with everybody right
right I'm just having an honest
conversation with folks about things
that mean something to them right and ya
know I have the same experience I do
with with with men well I have with
women with women are also seeking
acceptance right there's different ways
on how they want to accept it and one of
the biggest breakthroughs have recently
had which has obviously helped my own
you know my own marriage is this
recognition of you know you here our
wives and ladies pretty consistently
think feel and think that they're not
understood right and what I know no we
do understand you we do understand you
and it's like well no we really don't
because if you think about the amount of
things women go through to be a woman we
really will never understand them I
could you just imagine living that life
on a day-to-day basis right it's think
about the small things like a makeup in
a period and fixing your hair and
brushing your hair and he was like all
these different types of things I would
just [__] drive us nuts to do right I
shave once a week yeah I shower twice a
day and that's all I'd really do Yeah
right but then think about all these
other things that women have to do and
you're just like well in the amount of
game plans I've done with women you hear
and you see it's like holy [__] you
actually do go through so much in order
to just get to what we wake up's like
wake up being yeah you see they have to
go through a full-time job in order to
get to what we just wake up because
otherwise I'll be judged like a muffin
mmediately right and then that obviously
hones into what I believe is paralyzing
all humans and we're all suffered from
this exact same disease and I know it's
a disease that isn't going away so we
need to learn and figure out a way out
how to deal with it which is the disease
of fear yeah right fear is something we
consistently try to fight and say you
don't feel wasn't something I was
created for you to fight there's created
for you to be able to learn how to
embrace right and I think that once we
get to a stage where we embrace things
that we feel aren't going for us that's
the strength and I think that's what
becomes that that situation that helps
to lower water lower the water line a
bit and get people to start to
understand each other whether you'd be a
male or a female or whatever it may be
and just about getting to this common
understanding and all of us have this
desire of being accepted I think we
might like the the occupation of
stand-up comedy because it's funny you
mentioned like I think stand-up when
you're initially starting especially
you're so fearful of the unknown you're
fearful of the fact that you're not
going to be accepted you're fearful that
you're taking something that you thought
was funny you wrote on a napkin and then
you tell it on stage and I think as you
progressively go on in your in your
years and you get your 10,000 hours of
stand-up I think stand-ups in particular
it certainly for myself I've become less
fearful of trying things of like
experimenting with not like drugs or
anything but like you know you like
bungee jumping or something like that I
never would do that but after like the
constant rejection on a nightly basis of
taking something you wrote that day and
experimenting on stage and being told no
and getting over the fear of public
speaking all those other things that
happen early on in your career I think
it just as a stand-up I'm I'm less
fearful I'm definitely still scared of
things for sure but I think that I'm
willing to maybe tackle things or
experiment or try new things because of
the occupation of stand-ups I wouldn't
say that you're less fearful I would say
you have to just become more aware and
conscious of your ability yeah and you
like ability of that into anything
because you see if it works in comedy it
you practice a prop
with your wife you impact Asit with with
building a business and it's a really
good point you just made
it's a really good point and this is
where I think that like you know it's
one of the biggest things I like Jake
for example shields and iron in Gilbert
Melendez and Josh McDonald and Luke and
our whole crew of friends its we
consistently challenge each other like
listen you've won [__] world titles
you've reformed in front of millions of
people on in a cage where you could
potentially get your ass whooped and
everybody laughs at you for the rest of
your life and you've overcome that and
you know one let's not be like everybody
else and wait and tell our careers over
before we get into you know jumping into
other things or understanding you know
get into other fights in life and it's
it's it's that recognition as a you I
think you've probably acknowledged that
fact this isn't just limited to comedy I
can I can win at anything I can yeah oh
you just said something really
interesting which is that the fear never
goes away and it should ro it shouldn't
it shouldn't and I think a lot of people
that this idea of get over your fear be
fearless but that's that's a bets a
fool's errand that's an excuse it's an
excuse right it's it allows you to waste
defies and just allows you to justify
why you quit and it allows you to
justify on why not to be vulnerable why
not to accept why not to forgive and you
see a lot of warrants right a lot of
wars individuals that are extremely
insecure right who use the excuse of
fear it's why war happens right and and
these claims of like organizations and
groups and all that kind of [__] gets
created it's but how do you how do you
when you have so a lot of young guys are
listening right to this right and so oh
wait
hopefully but a lot of seventh the
longest searches penises I was gonna say
try and dicks but but for you just hope
you say it it's a lot that's exactly
right
it's but how do you um gameplan
what's the first thing you do for
somebody so because a lot of young guys
who always hit me I'm they're like and a
lot of young guys are lost a lot of
young guys don't know where to place
their energy right they don't so what do
you say to you to a young man when
you're game planning what's the first
thing to think about
well just think about how often we have
honest conversations with people right
so most have some sweet we blind
ourselves and make ourselves deaf the
truth consistently because it's easier
right like get in there and just talk
[__]
put people down do all the easiest
things you know that are out there it's
it can become a new societal norm and
this is where I think it's really
important for individuals who are
capable and aware of their impact and
their ability to start having really
honest conversations and what's the best
and most honest thing in the universe
it's actually being consciously the only
guarantee in this world which is what
death you're gonna die right it's just
being conscious of death being conscious
of death leads you to what it leads you
to be truthful talk on things right it
just makes things real right it makes
things really valuable it forces you to
become really measured and thoughtful
yeah right like in and really be able to
understand okay how do I react to this
with my heart or with my head and
consider right now that doesn't happen
like we don't really have an idea of
separation between when do I react with
my heart and when do I react with my
head what do I use my heart for what do
I use my head for so what would ease
your heart forces your head well I think
we use heart for grit and I think we
need to use our head for logic right
like more trying to force things that's
way to get what your heart wants right
correct used right I think it often we
try to be something we're not
and we put all of our heart behind this
and then like think about this like with
your head now like are you even meant to
be this or do this so so we it's like
the difference between working hard and
working smart I think yeah is but also
your heart yeah work smart yeah they
know that you've got a heart that could
support it why why beat this into the
ground it's primarily based around
something called a feeling right the
reason I'm so big on coaching feeling
it's funny when you come into our
facilities and you come in though I see
our team in our community and Brian
himself has been with me for a long time
when it comes these game plans it's it's
really interesting that you think
everybody in this world is legitimately
like busting their ass to be to win a
Super Bowl or to be a Pro Bowler to be a
world champion or to be the best you
know we get some particular numbers and
with with the comedy in views it's
really neat that that doesn't happen I
won't allow you to have that as a goal
my whole mission is primarily about the
consciousness of death and what you take
to your grave on your last breath and
the only thing you take to your last to
your grave on your last breath is just a
feeling
is it flying right and how often are we
how often how often are we
with that feeling right that has to be
something that's that's contentment it
really depends on everybody right now
you see you seen me do this a million
times
anybody I ask what does success mean to
you yeah it doesn't roll off no one's
tongue right so everyone's busting their
[__] ass without an interaction on
one meaning right it's and you'll see
the responses are always coming
immediately because of the fear of being
judged right oh you know no it means
money like that's not yours though what
do you mean it's not mine Izzy does it
going to your grave right
oh my job oh okay so you allow other
people to have their finger on the
trigger your faith in your destiny then
right right it's kind of like starting
to strip away all this [__] that we're
[__] sign me up where do I say I love
that question what does it mean you well
it's just truth right like you think
about all these things that we're
pushing and bust and ask for and like
sacrificing things and and and and and
obviously you know like getting made fun
of and putting you know people putting
you down and in doubt not like what
could be bigger than all of that right
it's you yeah and this is what we don't
do right we don't make ourselves a
priority there's so much [__]
self-neglect going on in society and in
the world that I'm talking about isn't
the whole world it's it's the world I'm
involved in I always refer to as my
world right right and in my world the
biggest issue I've seen pretty
consistently is that no one's ever lived
for themselves it's been about
fulfilling expectations it's been about
wanting to be x y&z be seen as X Y & Z
but my talk given to you that's all like
[__] I can put on you by your dad by
your by your [__] heritage blast
their culture you know etc but at the
same time to like we choose to play
victim to that right it's like you make
decisions on a day-to-day basis on what
you want to wear and what you want to
eat right well why the [__] don't you do
that when it comes to how you want to
feel why is it like oh I'm gonna start
working on the [__] you working on it
make a decision tell me you said to
those juvenile that you've not the kids
who are in juvie
this was pretty interesting you know
part of my part of my deal with my
stable with the athlete's side of things
not necessarily our you know corporate
partnerships and all that stuff but
empower but my athletes is you know a
lot of the athletes I work with are
individuals that always have a
a heavy story on why they're in a
situation right it's always individuals
that are kind of shitty situations and I
get though I get the the absolute
privilege to be able to be around and
work with and learn more about myself
why I'm so conscious of how they feel
about [__] is because I'm the most
insecure person in the world myself this
is why I'm such a workaholic right right
and and I battle these things like
hypocrisy I battle these inabilities to
forgive and if I don't coach it I'll
never get better at it myself so I'm
very selfish and why I do what I do
right which leads me to almost making my
stay what you guys have to do what I do
on a day-to-day basis if we were gonna
work together yeah and one of the
practices that we have is that you know
we've got four hours of practice a day
you know split times you've got you know
this read that we do together pretty
consistently just to be able to just
have that type of dialogue of thinking
going and when the other really
important parts to me are about
supporting causes in our community and
my younger brother Yosef as a police
officer in the Tenderloin he does a lot
of work with with juveniles and one of
the things we decided to do about three
years ago was you know let's go ahead
let's just start spending some time at
the juvenile hall here run these kids in
San Francisco shouldn't be [__] up mmm
like it's just this just you have
running water you have electricity
you've got you know not even one like
you should be changing the world
yeah so long story short we get in there
my whole stable is with me and everybody
gets up and kind of says their part
about to these kids and you know some of
the guys have been in juvie before some
of the guys have come from trouble
before and so they kind of share like
look we got ourselves out we got
ourselves out it was really interesting
they got goes my turn and obviously I
always just speak from the cuff like
always just my heart have nothing
prepared right and it was my opportunity
to speak and something hit me while I
was talking these kids was really cool
was very similar to our athletes these
kids I was talking on like you guys are
actually my you guys are the ones I want
these guys to be like huh and all
looking at me like what the [__] is this
idiot talking about wouldn't be like
girls like we're in sweats and sitting
in juvenile hall
I said no peep this we have to just get
a shift the narrative shift and I still
confuse I'm like listen I would die to
have these guys go the distance of
sacrificing their life for something
they believe in like you did you chose
the streets
you chose gangs you chosen they'll Majan
and then you you your commitment landed
you in jail so you were willing to take
the photo willing to sacrifice you for
what you believe in
now what if I told you there's this this
this this and this to believe it
yeah you only did that because that's
all you knew right now imagine if I
could make you a fighter imagine if I
can make you an entrepreneur imagine if
I can make yours and then I started
asking these questions like what would
you be like now that you but one kid
goes man I'd love to be a fashion
designer man look at my notebook I got
and I'm like listen that's the game it
really just comes down to have your
ability and and and in the capacity to
commit and also but also to take that
that passion that energy and just
[__] refocus it over here because you
were focusing it over here to be in the
baddest guy on the street down for your
gang down for your cause blah blah blah
all all the wrong place to point your
guns you tell them to take those guns
because they are full of ammo and strong
ammo and and and sure and if you're
willing to go to the extreme and this is
the extreme outcome is jail yeah right
imagine with the extreme of outcome of
education is imagines extreme outcome of
a career is imagine the way to frame it
was insane it just came but it was so
true and then like listening do you talk
a couple minutes to go to a bike when I
dumped in my 10,000 hours of comedy I
got to this space and it's like we'll
see you you realize what it does do ya
commit to something and you go go for
broke
that's really I mean that's what our
Kazim is when you look at yourself in
the mirror after that speech be like wow
I love them so this isn't stuff I come
up with this is stuff I experience and I
just share like these happens in
conversations with I think I've had the
most philosophical conversations in the
last eight years of my life has been
with bryon right because it's an
individual challenge is why I think the
way I think yeah and then it's like oh
should I know how to apply this to this
and it hits me as he's talking or we're
having conversations or we have these
group dinners with all these like really
interesting people that were really no
different than what people consider the
best in the world like we're all the
best in the world but take your shirt
off there's individuals I had it's
coming up in hours I'm sorry that's all
bears can we edit our house okay I mean
I'm Brian
come back sorry have come back come back
let's go to the next current event how's
the great speech talking
yeah that's tarkas een that's why I love
him that's why that's why target that's
why Brennen shop and I always say
Targa's een you you and your brother are
the best people in the world Steve
you're not bad man go ahead speaking of
commitment
an Australian father of three died last
December because he's known amongst his
group of friends for being the guy who
will never turn down a dare at a
Christmas party his friends dared him to
eat a live gecko which he did and he
basically grin and bear dit through the
pain for about ten days until finally he
just had enough he went to the hospital
where they have to induce him into a
coma they found that he actually had
salmonella that got so bad that his body
was just trying to get rid of the poison
that was essentially in his stomach he
started leaking all these fluids and he
eventually actually passed away this is
in the news now because his family is
actually trying to sue the hospital for
malpractice they're saying that they
should have given him a catheter in
order to kind of release some of the
fluids from his body and that's what led
to his death oh yeah well you don't
expect I guess when people are
somebody's leaking from their testicles
which are yes red besides great balls
gravels and his balls were leaking
typically that's where you go I just
wanna go balls
maybe i and be honest it's why we got go
you pull up your cup ouple wall and did
you swallow it say yes or no but it's a
yes or no question
yeah it's a yes or no question but I yes
or no party line I like the part I asked
you a yes-or-no question did you swallow
my friend
rapists look at my balls oh there they
are and they're leaking everywhere god
somebody hasn't jerked off for years
Oh swollen balls why wear elastic pants
you [__] that's a bomber what a
shitty way to die it is horrible and you
don't want to die in a dumb way right
yeah that coke balls on you swallow a
gecko lots of ways to die that just suck
not sucking like when the vending
machine falls on somebody at the break
room it's like oh yeah it's over a Pepsi
right yeah how do you say that being
kicked to death by a cassowary what
would be the coolest day to die
that would be a way ya know it's a way
that you'd be like guys well anything
like a you know Dwayne Johnson movie
where you're like saving somebody but
you actually didn't make it I think
saving somebody from a big cat a big
cats coming you go get in a car and you
run and the cat takes you but you but
you die fighting though there are these
two girls I know you die fighting
[__] against a big cat um unless you're
a man cat like myself in which case you
get behind him these two gals were in
the food and they were in some area of
[__] Australia near the sea and the
guy said to the girls I wouldn't go in
the water here he's a guy from there
yeah I wouldn't go on the water here
because there have been some crocodiles
some salties we've seen the water now
when I say that what do you guys do what
do you say I go swimming you go okay
right yeah go okay you know you do did
you say Salty's if I hear there are
crocodiles if I hear there are
crocodiles in the Atlantic yeah I'm not
going in the Atlantic like I like they
salt did you say salties you said
saltwater crocodiles yeah cuz you know
that you swim the saltwater crocodile
once you swim with once twice twice you
swam once
okay there they are there they are
that's a dinosaur and he will eat you
because you are a state
to him as anything he ever eats so huh a
salty pull that bad boy up there no yeah
that's not the last thing I'll see I
went to Costa Rica why I went to Costa
Rica two years ago yeah to go surfing
this in this town called Nosara
ah and I spent five days there six days
there and my fourth day there we went to
this dinner after we talked a little
jiu-jitsu samurai was in town
and these guys were talking about where
we were surfing yeah and it's kind of
where the river meets right the ocean
and it's like you know there's you know
you know that this whole entire you know
area rats full of saltwater crocodiles
and I'm like what Jesus yeah literally
was walking across the beach ago didn't
Twitter say yeah and this is day four
and I saw two days of surfing laughs oh
God and I've got like privates with this
badass surf coach and I'm so geeked up
and like yeah I'm gonna do all the to
all that immediately right there's where
I faked my back was hurt
yeah and I didn't go back in the water
for today I get the deposit back no I
have a big scar on my back my back
operation just kept left without my
shirt yeah my back that's been down you
know tastic then I went to yoga because
if you were to and a crocodile actually
came through well well that's and that
would be a smart thing to do because I
was with my kids and there was add
they'd spotted a fifty-mile Crockett on
the beach that morning my kids are in
the water I go get out of the water
we're not gonna be in this water that's
what you do so these two gals were like
oh well we'll just jump in the water
anyway well guess what that right there
came up and grabbed her friend she said
the last thing I saw was her face as the
croc was taking her a well but but wait
of course that happened of course that
happened as a [__] guide who's there
said we'd seen Salty's in the area so
damn don't so she's like event here you
go she's looking at her friend yeah yeah
that's what happens that was he was he
was she was screaming she look there she
goes I saw her face as she was being
taken away Oh God well don't do that
anymore
so this is a kangaroo it's a kangaroo
looking those things look at the Sun I
think they are and Jesus yeah enjoy that
dinosaur you think he gives a [__] about
you that's water he pulls you in till
you see that when my when my when I was
on comic view when my wife and her and
Mike my kids were in Africa they were
they were camped and there was a aha I
heard you call it Africa Africa there
was a thing like that and you didn't
know it was a swamp Chuck full of Crocs
shuffle and I never used the word
Chuck but chuck full Crocs know if I
ever say to you that area over there's
chuck full Crocs get the [__] away from
me
dammit alright next current event
these are depressing I've got a severely
depressing so here we go this is my
speed yep a 26 year old man who worked
at a temp agency was moved around for a
year and everywhere he worked for some
reason there was always a weird toilet
clog issue in the women's bathroom and
one day a woman actually caught him
trying to stick some sort of bottle into
a woman's toilet and have it clogged up
he did this for an entire year they went
back to the other places he attempt at
and found that they had the same issues
so a judge mm-hmm so a judge actually
sentenced him to a hundred and fifty
days in jail with three years probation
good he didn't hurt anybody but they're
sure that he'll do it again
this has my girls [__] in the work
place and why am I sitting or being in
the work so what type of what type of
group does he run with him in jail the
toilet the clogged log loggers cloggers
and we're not talking about Dutch shoes
the toilet clog was ranked sixth above
penises in points you guys know that it
was well there was a guy who I used to
[__] in my boarding school he was there
was a guy was [__] on top of the
toilet that your honor he'd [__] on top
on top of you know the flusher
that part with the water he would take a
clean nice round poopoo right there and
he was doing that everywhere and they
never caught him and he wrote I believe
he wrote the mad [__] strikes again
jitter yeah he left a calling card
hi he says leave a call I mean he used
to always leave a calling card Patrick
Beeman's dad can I tell you but about
the first time ever first the only time
I ever [__] my pants um I was in Ohio
and I met this girl who's before I met
my wife and I brought her back to my
room and we hung out had a great time
and all that stuff and I had to go do
morning radio so I go do morning radio
and I came back and I turn like 31 and
someone had told me I forget what comic
he was he's like once you turn 30 within
that first year or two you're gonna [__]
your pants there's no way I'm never
gonna [__] my pants I love dudes who
have these truths you start [__]
he's like you're gonna [__] your pants
is like okay so I write
I basically I went and did morning radio
and I came back and I pressed the button
in the elevator and it's going up and I
had just this the intense hot flash I'd
never had something like that before
just it came over me like a wave and
instantly like sweat beads permeated on
my forehead and I just go oh what was
that and boom just instant yardsale on
your answer right in your poo poo pants
I just [__] my pants it just came out
bad like gigs like there wasn't even
like a thought of like did I just [__]
it was like I definitely just [__] my
pants no I knew it and then the doors
open I'm like mouths [__] so I come out
and then I go to my hotel room oh my
gosh [__] what the girl still in my room
and I swiped the key she's still in the
room like [__] so I shut the door I took
my pants off and I ran over by the Pepsi
machine I threw my pants away yeah come
back to took a shower nobody knows I
[__] my pants right yeah I crawl into
the bed yeah the girl wakes up she goes
oh my god I go what she goes oh god I go
what she goes I'm so sorry
Oh what are you sorry about she goes
sometimes want to drink too much I
pissed the bed and I pissed your bed I'm
really sorry and I was like it's cool
she goes what I got yeah it's cool yeah
she goes you're being really nice about
this uh psych yeah yeah well human she's
like well thanks for being so cool I'm
in my head I'm like you want to see how
cool I am follow me to the Pepsi machine
let's see how cool yeah the one time I
was really cool is I met these two gals
and one of them liked me and her friend
was very drunk and he held the camera
they had to get back in there to get
back somewhere too far and I and they
didn't know what to do and they have
money I go you know what you could stay
at my mom's place with me and I was just
cool and this is New York City and I was
a young dude and I think I was trying to
hook up with a friend that I knew that
wasn't really gonna happen it just
wasn't working long story short I did
hook up with a friend of thing and her
friend who was really drunk ended up
I made her a bed on the couch and then
for whatever reason my mom came home
early well it's what forever whatever
she lives there
yeah but she wasn't for whatever reason
my mom came home had a kid or something
so she comes into the apartment and the
girl is at the doorway sleeping with a
sheet wrapped around her in a puddle of
her own pee and that was good that's
what your mama pissed herself
sorry also sorry for having sex with
this girl in your bed Brian can you stop
going to happy hour Chili's please stop
bringing this home stop myself yeah I go
and mom sometimes guy got it [__] your
sons guy because that's what he does
because he's good guy and he likes to
spread his essence and sometimes he's
got a gig yeah but you guys I don't know
what that means I go I'll spell it now
clean up that girl's peepee put her in
the shower cuz busy and you're my mom
and this is your floor my mom I'm sorry
for kicking over here and sorry about
the pears this fall on CW the worst son
ever
brahim gone up her piss mama
Friday nights
[__] meter hits red-hot with Bryan
Callen well there you go
any other tournament that a few more you
want some more yeah that's a real clog
yeah okay so I love messing with Steve
yeah so a father actually sent his 14
year old son to the airport and the
flight was supposed to be from North
Carolina and then there's a transfer
flight they would eventually get the 14
year old boy to Sweden and he paid $150
for United Airlines to walk the boy from
his connecting flight to the correct
flight that would ultimately get him to
his location and the United Airlines
person who was appointed to take this
kid to the right gate actually took him
to a different gate and put him on a
flight to Germany and the 14 year old
boy while he was sitting in his seat no
but kind of looked around and realized
oh [__] I'm on the wrong flight alerted
somebody and the pilot actually had to
go back and drop him off they later got
him actually take him to Germany no they
were about to take off when he finally
realize it was like that my favorite
joke about Steve's is like when when
girls call you and they're like you'll
never guess what almost happens to use
like nothing cuz it was almost by those
two jokers
also how girls are always cold chili
I'll see you talk about how they wear
those high heels high heels and by the
end of the night it looks like a
Thriller video yeah a hundred fifty yeah
you pay your hundred 150 bucks you
expect to get your kid to the goddamn
gate not always do but it's United it's
you know they all suck by the way all
the airlines not your American you're
American I'm not gonna be after like
this week I'm done I have like two more
flights with them
[__] done I hit my 2 million miler
I'm [__] they're all [__] garbage
it's like the presidential election it's
like you don't like any of them but
you're like I got to choose one I guess
and that's what it's like for me with
flying now I might just go online we
need more competition there's some
reason and I think that jet sweet x
thing needs to really pick up and be old
yes we need just more makeup it's so
convenient so clean usual I would I've
never used it I heard about it yeah it's
hard because it's Burbank right yeah and
there needs to Monica and there needs to
be a couple more airlines that just fly
to those so whenever I have to do gigs
in like if it's Albany you're taking 17
flights I'm like I'm not you know who's
your carrier who to use I use Delta
mostly yeah are they good are they
reliable are they want I yeah delay
Delta's pretty good I think the only
since America Louis which I write as the
word never it's like DMV now United's
cartridge yeah it's miserable I played I
paid first-class ticket and I was like
these are the seats I did the exact same
plaintiff in my fifties and I couldn't
recline oh you couldn't reply after a
nine-hour delay in Chicago oh my god
maintenance issues oh my god how do all
the ha do all these not have TVs by the
way no yeah how do you make it just be
better it's not that hard your house is
it we're in America yeah great JetBlue
is awesome when it first came out
JetBlue is awesome JetBlue in like
subway we're awesome when they came out
and then they just slowly decided and it
just like [__] is this a turkey sandwich
well somebody says you get on a plane in
the bathroom stinks oh yeah
clean hey clean the bathroom of call
that Syriac lager is going around
probably just clogs yes yes clogging
bastard keep the clog ripped off the
airlines next current event I've never
shared on an airplane by the way I have
sure maybe never done it I do it I try
to do it on purpose so that they can
understand come on one up just one more
yeah two more one more
there's a nice way of communicating I
understand you do know we've been a long
I'd rather be here all day
but are you inside me at all Steve oh
sorry MMA mixed martial arts are Kazim
is you guys are for sure so you heard
about the announcement Michelle Waterson
and you Lana y NJ check yes it's over
twelve shells my gals pn+ nineteen
that's a crazy crazy
yeah dude so yeah they're matching up
fever blockers no good for me I don't
know either them but I'll look at how
look at the pictures of them and I'll
tell you who went on the Maciek uses
what lavato of peds everyone's been
saying that I don't know a fan's insane
dude
two great fighters you're honoring Jen
Jake is no joke
I love her but I love Michelle - I'm so
happy for Michelle because this was she
was looking for this no Michelle is she
do you think yes ty yeah and I believe
white so I have to beso to you because
I'm green and Irish I have to go for her
but I would I would think that the
bookworm is unsuspecting yeah well there
nah she's an assassin an assassin she's
an absolute assassin but Michelle's game
I think his way more diverse really got
a lot more to offer really so your
money's on Michelle my money's on
Michelle Michelle is yoked
well she's jacked Michelle is mr. ty
it's her time when is it October 12 yeah
you wanna yet it's hard to beat though
she is a kind badass that's a great
fight I'm really looking forward to that
um I don't know if she's actually half
white but she does look half white kinda
yeah I was like I talked to either one
of these John could destroy like 80% of
the Comedy Store right okay until they
got to like yeah you guys well then I'd
be like she's slipping I'm trained by
Tariq Aziz if you I stepped in the ring
with either of me I'm not sure good
smoking I make any comment but the
answer is but the answer is the answer
is yes I would I believe that they would
be Mia yeah oh man I wouldn't last a
second it's worth this race what they do
yeah all the time so I mean don't kid
yourself my boxing is scary United
Airlines to fly 238
last one this woman is pretty crazy the
skies from Hawaii is Hawaiian Hawaiian
he's Hawaiian and in 2016 he got in a
road rage incident where he attacked
like he caused or someone caused the
road rage I'm not sure if he calls it or
they did but he's the one that cut them
off made them stop an Asian cutting
someone off in traffic this is unheard
of and then a he
was literally attacking these two guys
that were in the car
you know stabbing them stabbing that
he's pepper spray them and started
stabbing them and then a Good Samaritan
try to stop it he got stabbed too and
I'll just play this guy's a testimony
that's tonight without that he said that
there's a look well the toys the ones
you don't expect right yeah that's scary
why does he look like he was standing in
front of an exhaust case in court char
was driving home to ever bets the attack
right there Jesus Christ
other drivers stabbing and slashing them
he was convicted of attempted murder and
two counts well he has a life sentence
now he was life Sestak this was a case
you inside that you provoked that you
almost killed an innocent motor I didn't
have been there with you cut off the
evidence showed there was no evidence on
my part my lawyer failed to put in my
video he put no evidence on my behalf
not on my hands the image of my evidence
was submitted mr. Charnin Ana judge top
it was weird but his statement was also
weird - yeah this will show that oh now
this kangaroo court is giving me a life
sentence for me trying to protect and
defend myself against the attack from
three days in essence treating me like a
black man and that's his lawyer
obviously I'm like this is because I
prepared myself to play my part in your
kangaroo court treating me like a black
man so today I'm going to be a black man
Oh crazy right
oh he's going away for life so but I you
can't get out of a car with pepper spray
and not and knife and stab dudes yeah
not allowed to do that you need to know
that as a grown man I was like an asian
joy as she was like really crazy
yeah well Spokane Washington next week
July 11 12 and 13 I'm coming to Spokane
comedy club get your tickets now I'll be
in San Francisco Cobbs
where Tariq will not because you'll be
caught you'll be in
Mike Lee's corner for his fight because
you help them train Mike but I will be
at Cobbs July 19th and 21st show you
haven't been to dude yeah at San
Francisco honey I was hoping you I he
wants me to get laryngitis I just can't
yeah you learn tight especially big
Brown will be in Cincinnati Ohio the
weekend I am in Spokane he's there July
12th and 13th at the funny bone and that
he's in Indianapolis at helium July 18
and 19 and 20 so check him out
Nashville he'll be there August 1 2 & 3
that's big brown alright we're excited
oh yeah my energy went down no work
sided guys Steve burned the amazing
Jonathan
yes YouTube YouTube it's absolutely for
free just type in always amazing you'll
see the Jonathan dock I teamed up with
Bill burr and Al magical so we just put
it out there so as many people as
possible can see it and we put it out
it's got a crazy amount of views and you
know like the the comments section could
be a toilet yeah so we were like part of
it were like we're like do we put the do
we enable the comments on this film and
we put the comments up and it's been
nothing but positive yeah well it
doesn't surprise me it's been very nice
looks always great and you're great so
that doesn't surprise me where can they
find you everything I have a Steve Byrne
life be yr and alive and I'll be why are
if you live in New Orleans I'm doing a
benefit my for my friend she's a single
mom she had cancer she's got a lot of
bills so I'm gonna go do a show there at
one-eyed Jack's July 17th Wednesday July
17 or good mom and get all everything
from the doors gonna go to her and her
daughter and then go to West Palm Beach
improv after that so I love it tark also
tarkas een one of my favorite people
thank you for giving us so nice meeting
you get is fun get to hang you know
likewise I mean just listening the two
funniest human beings in the world as
witty and as fast as you guys are is
really you hold your own brother I felt
yeah I just got my ass walk that's not
true that's not true
yeah that's not true yeah why'd your
voice change that target
tops for Dubois always changes when you
notice one no it's not true which
invoice that's not true at all buddy
where can I find your tart I asked you a
question please answer the question you
working there [__] so I can find them
they can find them in a much higher tax
bracket I think yeah tarik
what is it Tarkas back no at-tariq
at-tariq ya ta r eq EQ done yeah
Afghanistan Korea and America in the
house huh he's Caucasian and Asian makes
them Caucasian yeah there's the father
of the kid we're out